hi there Steve Kaufman and today again I
want to talk about communicating in
language learning it's so important we
communicate when we speak obviously but
we also communicate when we listen and
read and the other day on our forum at
link someone said that they had been
working at link and listening and
reading and they felt as if they weren't
making any progress they didn't feel
that they understood any better than
three months earlier they had done a 90
day challenge at length I'm going to ask
that person are you listening to and are
you reading things that you're really
interested in in other words is this
compelling content this is something
that stephen krashen refers to all the
time compelling content if what you are
reading and listening to is a great
interest to you and I might add if
you're listening to something where you
enjoy the voice and the subject is of
interest and possibly the subject is
familiar to you I don't see how you
can't understand more and more if on the
other hand you're listening to something
that's not interesting and you're
listening over and over again yes you
are going to basically stop progressing
because the brain requires things that
are stimulating even in terms of
learning content it has to be
stimulating in some way and I have made
reference in previous videos to this
interleaving that it's a good idea
sometimes to leave some something that
you're working on go and do something
else study some other subject and then
come back to it and all of this
refreshes the brain and the brain learns
better rather than trying to sort of
learn a block of something or force
yourself to learn something that's not
very interesting to you so communicating
is is the best way to learn
communication whether it be listening
and reading which I consider to be
communicating or speaking this is the
key to learning but it has to be
compelling it has to be you know of
interest and the more compelling the
nicer the voice in your ears the more
you are attracted to the subject
better you're going to learn so remember
stephen krashen with his compelling
content it has to be compelling if it's
very compelling it can be very difficult
for you but you'll work your way through
it so communicating but meaningful
compelling communication thanks for
listening